thierry gaulin fondée il ya longtemps
maintenant une association ovni
languedoc et j'arrivais pas à savoir si
si si vous y croyez vous à leur présence
chez nous ou pas non alors vous avez
compris que chez nous la croyance mais
ne fait pas partie du phénomène
aérospatial non identifié par contre je
vous dirai à titre personnel si les
extraterrestres débarquent et de
maintenance jardin je serais content ça
y'a pas photo mais on ne raisonne pas en
terme de croyance et on va on va plutôt
raisonner en termes de fait en termes
journalistiques scientifique
éventuellement puisqu'on a quelques
scientifiques dans l'association aussi
dans notre démarche c'est celle là mais
quand vous dites vous seriez content
j'imagine la satisfaction on serait tous
contents d'avoir la réponse soit oui
mais en même temps il faudrait
s'inquiéter non parce qu'ils s'y sont
dans votre jardin
ils ont une supériorité technologique
sion nous qui est tel que a priori ça
risque de mal se passer pour nous
j'entends ça peut effectivement mal se
passer à l'échelle des sociétés humaines
on a constaté effectivement que qu'à une
société possédant une technologie
supérieure rencontre une société qui a
une technologie en retard généralement
ça se passe plutôt mal pour la seconde
y'a qu'a voir un petit peu ce qui s'est
passé aux amériques par exemple mais
peut-être qu'on peut aussi envisager une
situation où la civilisation qui
arriverait avec une technologie
supérieure soit à même de faire en sorte
que tout se passe bien alors quand je
disais que je serais content qu'ils
soient dans le jardin bien évidemment si
c'est la bestiole d'alien là je serai
moins contents mais si ce sont des
extraterrestres qui qui qui ont envie de
prendre contact et qui sont rationnels
du moins ce que nous en plus ça serait
mieux d'ailleurs là je serai content
oui
[Musique]